way draymond on the push steph running
with boulder
steph himself mulder got the rebound
didn't give up on it
[Applause]
here comes steph
[Applause]
these scattered situations he shot the
lights out
the pelicans trying to turn that's a
different way to defend curry right
there
is turn the power off when the warriors
have the ball
lights out wow
that's that's crazy you know i know
defensively like wilt could block out
the sun but that's a little different
right there
coach kerr doesn't like it
steph curry doesn't like it
you got two defenders on him
and you're turning the lights out now
here's the one thing i would say
and the officials are going to have to
talk to somebody about it and they they
just adjusted
good job you can't have the shot clock
go down to six
when three seconds would expire because
it was black that's true
this is a new way to defend it we
thought we'd see everything box in one
two defenders three defenders and no
lights see now what steph's saying is i
made that shot
nobody saw it but i made that he
probably did but they reset the shot
clock to eight so